the corona virus pandemic is
dramatically changing our everyday lives
throughout the week we're examining what
this new normal looks like including how
we work socialize and get life-saving
information already a majority of people
are staying inside their homes our lead
national correspondent David Begg know
is one of them he reached out to people
across the country to see what their new
normal is at home David good morning
they Anthony good morning I am at home
under self quarantine because I had a
brief contact with a colleague who
tested positive for the virus
I have no symptoms I have not been
tested but the company asked me to stay
home as a precaution
and I was more than happy to honor that
so we wanted to talk to people who are
at home on what is a beautiful morning
here in New York City and around the
country either because they are self
quarantined like me or because they're
answering the call of their country to
stay home my name is John Michael
visible cassio I'm Kimberly McCullough
this couple from Nashville Tennessee
says they've been tracking Kovac 19
since January and that is why they are
now self quarantined in their apartment
this is a decontamination station in
process and step for social distancing
when entering the house the Gonzalez
family home in the Bronx of New York
City is now a classroom for
four-year-old ramesses and his 13 year
old sister Haley she's been using Google
classroom to interact with her teachers
and peers 17 year old high school senior
Meg Boone sent us this video from her
home in McKinney Texas which is right
outside Dallas just kind of hard I was
just like a normal teenage kid to think
well what's gonna happen next what about
college what about my diploma what about
finishing high school what's next my
greatest fear is bringing something home
to them Mona mualim is working from home
in New York City she cares for her 90
year old father and 78 year old mother I
go to grocery stores late at night after
midnight to make sure I'm minimizing
exposure a same thing with pharmacies
you know I don't take cabs anywhere I
won't or
Uber's I stay six feet away from my
parents at all times and it's hard in
the house in the house in the house and
and that's been tough David you know
like they're anxious they're terrified
and I can't hug them I can't give them
like hold their hand you know and again
I recognize that maybe some of the
things I'm doing you know maybe they're
a little bit extreme but I cannot carry
that kind of guilt so should something
happen to them and then there's the
story of our CBS news radio colleague
Bill rake-off bill and his family were
not able to be by his mother's side when
she died this past weekend from natural
causes they couldn't be there because of
new guidance that prevents nursing home
visits unless the person is dying but
Bill and his family didn't know how
imminent his mother Laura Lee's death
was bill reflected on his dad's devotion
to his mom he had been her staunchest
advocate and caretakers always taken her
to the doctor always advocating always
stepping in when a hospitalist or a
doctor didn't get it and making sure
that they got it and ironically on her
last day of life he couldn't be there
our sincerest condolences to our
colleague bill and to the entire
rake-off family two other reflections
from my conversations with Americans
over the last couple of days there are
so many people who work freelance and
are wondering when that Nix paycheck is
going to come and literally are living
paycheck to paycheck and also I don't
know but the world seems a bit nicer
even here in New York City with all the
hustle and bustle and meanness that can
be it seems a bit kinder so I will be
home through Sunday on self quarantine
but don't feel bad for me Paddington is
he's getting so big and he's so cute
thank you David thank you very much and
David's right kindness always works yes
that's the thing I worry about like you
said yesterday Tony we made me socially
distant but we have to not be
emotionally distant because human touch
is so important many of us can't you
can't touch this can't do that well we
want to know what your new normal looks
like as the coronavirus changes the way
we work the way we parent our children
and the way we
with other people please share your
story on twitter by using the hashtag my
new normal or by emailing us at
coronavirus at CBS news.com who knows
maybe we'll be able to share your story
with our viewers